a primeira que agradecer a oportunidade
está aqui é o ciúme sente muito honrada
quando recebi o convite mas vou
confessar que até ontem eu não tinha
muita noção do que a falar de inovação
pra vocês
então eu recorri um grande mestre o
grande mentor meu que sempre me ajuda
com experiência e com os conselhos dele
eu perguntei o que é inovação quem
inovação pra você na sua opinião o
grande mestre google ele conhece ele uma
das definições que ele me deu foi que
inovação é uma invenção que ela ganha
vida tenha mercado é uma invenção que
ela se torna presidente só queria pensar
nisso e me perguntei é uma invenção
será que não é cada uma das nossas vidas
aqui
será que nós mesmos não somos a nossa
própria invenção já parou pra pensar com
mais de sete bilhões de pessoas que
estão vivas neste momento só você é você
então eu queria antes de começar a
celebrar as invenções únicas incríveis
que a gente tem aqui mas pra isso a
gente vai ter que estar presente nesse
momento aqui pra isso eu vou pedir pra
todo mundo levantar porque não vou
precisar de atenção de vocês vão
precisar da presença do corpo da mente e
da alma de vocês
então pra isso já levantaram então vocês
não estão só esperando a agir agora olhe
à sua volta percebe as outras menções
incríveis que estão ao seu lado percebe
o valor que a gente juntos ganha então
cruza os braços com vista ao seu lado
por favor
percebe a força que todo mundo junto
pode ter só que pra essas invenções
ganharem vida e tem que lembrar que a
gente está vivo
então por favor vão direita
e quando eu falar já quando eu falar já
você vai gritar 5º ano mais forte que
você conseguir o seu primeiro no ano
difícil né
o primeiro nome lembrou beleza gente
confia no seu amigo você não passar
vergonha
lá em confiança
agora sim é celebrado olha só então hoje
eu queria contar um pouco da minha
experiência da minha busca pessoal
interminável por ter uma vida inovadora
e alguns aprendizados que tem tido com
isso
então pra começar tudo né o início
quando era aquela criancinha
seguindo a regra né de quem tem olho
puxado sendo uma criança muito fofa e eu
me divertia e dançava eu pouco cantava
sonhava tal e de vez em quando aqueles
encontros familiares é o quando tinha
essa seres chamados adultas ao meu redor
eu ouvia de vez em quando assim
aproveita aproveita enquanto você pode
aproveitar essa fase
resolvido isso é realmente não foi
sozinho mesmo
eu comecei a perguntar por que aproveita
será que a vida não é pra ser
aproveitada ao sentido da vida
eu comecei a crescer e eu comecei a
conhecer esses dados e comecei a me
tornar com doenças agudas e eu comecei a
perceber o porquê de tanta gente que
aconselhará as crianças aproveitarem
aquela fase é simplesmente pelo fato de
que a gente vai crescendo e aí eu
percebi que o medo que eu tinha de
morrer
na verdade não era medo de morrer se
transformou num grande medo de morrer
sem ter vivido uma vida que tenha valido
a pena
de morrer sem ter deixado um legado sem
ter feito a diferença
tem tem inovado com a minha invenção e
com informação desmente mais uma
invenção
então comece a crescer e procurar por
essa resposta como eu poderia fazer isso
como com com aquela crise existencial
constante
eu cheguei na faculdade eu comecei a
perceber que a maioria da galera sabia
onde queria chegar saber o que queria
fazer
mas pouca gente sabia porque eu comecei
a perguntar isso qualquer diferença
entre ter um propósito qualquer
diferença entre porque é um objetivo
qualquer diferença para compensar a
diferença entre propósito e um objetivo
em uma conversa com um grande professor
meu plano é ficar
a gente chegou num conceito legal de que
ele chegou na verdade de propósito
nada mais é do que um objetivo que
transcende a sua própria pessoa e foi
nesse momento que faz sentido o que
tanta gente fala mandela falou o que
importa na sua vida é o que você viveu
mas a diferença é que você fez na vida
dos outros e aí as coisas começam a
ficar um pouco mais claras é como se
tivesse ganhado um pouco de direção é
ainda não sabe o caminho mas a direção
tabela a contribuição fazer com que a
minha vida não foi só sobre mim mesmo só
que pra contribuir com o mundo eu
precisaria aprender sobre o que eu
poderia fazer para contribuir
então eu cheguei no sentido para a vida
também pelo menos é aprender e
contribuir e aí eu comecei a procurar
por isso é incrível porque quando você
tem um pouco da noção da direção que
você quer seguir
parece que tudo ao seu redor começa a se
moldar em relação aquilo parece que tudo
em volta começa a se tornar uma
oportunidade mas que tudo fica
distorcida e ganha as cores daquela
direcção que você determinou aquele foco
que você criou
e aí eu vi uma oportunidade de assistir
uma palestra
exatamente dois anos atrás em que meu
coração bateu eu me arrepiei
eu senti meu coração na garganta
eu me emocionei por um projeto que eu
nunca tinha visto um propósito da
crítico e impossível do jeito que eu sou
eu depois do evento
cheguei pra esse empreendedor que
aparece falei olha faz tanto sentido
trabalhar por isso que eu largo tudo
trabalhar com você pra aprender com você
pra contribuir com isso então eu decidir
que eu ia deixar a universidade trancado
matrícula ou deixar tudo e me mudar para
um lugar muito chato na prática um
sacrifício pra trabalhar por propósito
para trabalhar por algo que fizesse eu
senti que o meu tempo estava sendo usado
estava sendo vivido que ele estava
simplesmente assistindo a minha vida no
piloto automático e aí foi uma
experiência maravilhosa mas depois de
seis meses
a minha contribuição do projeto terminou
só que eu tinha aprendido muito mas
talvez não tivesse contribuído com o meu
melhor e poderei pensar no melhor e é
falar eu sempre gostei de falar eu
pensei poxa porque eu não trabalho eo
propósito de falar eu tive a idéia de
conversar com pessoas e cria ambientes
para jovens do ensino médio
universitários em empresas ambientes em
que a gente pudesse refletir nos nossos
próprios porque este ano porque de cada
um porque são todos diferentes
cada um tem sua própria invenção bom
tanto quanto o de tanto no momento em
que eu deixei a universidade quanto
quando tive essa ideia aos 20 anos
eu recebi diversas críticas algumas
sugestões idéias medo de ninguém
senão ninguém você não tem um
certificado
você não tem dinheiro não tem idade não
tem experiência não tem nome e não têm
qi quem indica
não tem nem ricos e não é por um tempo
eu fiquei mal e até pensei em desistir
só que eu percebi é que tudo isso que
estão falando não era quem eu sou não
era o meu ser e não simplesmente os
rótulos que algumas pessoas dão e que
esses - na verdade eram simplesmente um
benções da cabeça da cabeça de cada um
porque na verdade o medo é nossa mente
fria quando você fala não vai dar certo
vai dar errado você está falando isso
com fundamento
santhanam isso com pesquisa científica
está falando isso por um medo que você
criou se arriscar sair da zona de
conforto
ele não tem base e não é real
então se ele não era real será uma
criação de outras pessoas
eu não podia fazer com que isso viesse a
minha vida e eu decidi confiar no que
era real de verdade que era o momento
meu coração bater nos momentos em que eu
sinto que eu tô aqui presente
e aí tudo fica muito mais fácil você tem
um propósito porque um grande mentor
medissem que 99% das pessoas
decidi com a razão então a gente analisa
o risco em que analisa os caminhos
a gente vê que vai fazer mais antiga e
aí a gente decide e depois a gente
coloca o coração pra fazer aquilo em um
por cento as pessoas não fazem o
contrário elas vestirem com o coração
descida em com o que faz a gente nem
vivos e depois elas agem somente a fazer
com que aqueles membros não têm
fundamento e que aquele risco que em
proporções que a gente nem imagina
e aí me falaram que não era certo isso
aqui no total e
dois anos depois daquele dia em que eu
tomei a decisão de deixar a universidade
eu criei o emprego das nações o que eu
faço o que eu amo viagem por isso e
ainda sou remunerado é bom e pensando
nisso tudo
eu chego uma grande contradição que a
gente tem a nosso redor
uma grande contradição que é o que nos
impede de dar aquele passo além e é uma
grande contradição que nos impede de dar
simplesmente compensação aqui aquele um
centímetro a mais para tomar a decisão
porque para pensar aquela ação aquele
aprendizado que você quer você fica na
beira do penhasco você olha só que a
gente não aprende
eu percebi que a gente só aprende quando
se jogou porque a gente tem que aprender
tem que aprender a voar na queda não
imaginando como você vai voar e essa
contradição que impede da gente impede
também que dar esse passo é algo na
sociedade
chama dualidade uma dualidade entre o
que é normal o que é diferente
e olha que interessante crescendo a todo
tempo
então se eu for menino e desenhar um
elefante rosa com asas e brincar de
barbie 1
isso vai ser diferente o da
credibilidade social
até aí beleza sim o que é normal tudo
bem
a legal aprovada o que é interessante a
partir do momento em que o que era
normal no começo eu quero é diferente um
começo se desenvolvem para pensar em
qualquer projeto em qualquer pessoa
qualquer
a pista que teve para pensar na
admiração por qualquer coisa na sua vida
porque que vocês milhões é porque ela é
normal é porque ela é diferente e para
pensar nas coisas normais as coisas mais
na verdade a última hora
então olha que contradição a gente é
ensinado a criticar e voltar pra baixo
que é diferente é normal só que na
verdade quando a gente virar adulta de
verdade nessa balança ela troca de lado
e só o que é diferente é valorizado
então eu queria concluir dizendo talvez
uma das conclusões que tenha chegado é
que inovação é mais do que uma invenção
um projeto um produto uma empresa ou
isso ou aquilo
inovação nada mais é do que uma escolha
ea escolha o que a gente tem que fazer
em relação às nossas próprias vidas
a nossa vida autêntica o nosso cunho
próprio e decidir se a gente vai pegar
todos os medos e limites e rótulos que
estão ao nosso redor ea gente vai
aceitar eles retornarem os nossos e
acreditar que a gente não pode
ou a gente vai descobrir o que a gente
realmente é descobrir o porquê dessa
dimensão tá viva hoje